good morning everyone if you would
please rise and join me for the pledge
of allegiance
i pledge algiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
republic for it stands one nation under
God indivisible with liberty and justice
for all
okay i hereby open executive session for
daily
list HP 380 and I recognize
Representative Rhodess to make a motion
uh thank you Mr chairman um I move ITL
second seconded by Representative Pru
would you like to speak to your motion
uh sure um I I do apologize that is the
one bill that I do not have in front of
me but if I'm remembering correctly that
bill
is taking away the penalty if you are
caught selling your medical cannabis
and the reason that that that penalty
was put at that level was
because the other body was not really in
favor of of of the therapeutic cannabis
program and they set that penalty at
that level for a reason so um I know the
testimony we heard is that nobody's
doing that so the whole thing is
ridiculous at the end of the day if
nobody's doing it then I guess we don't
have anything to worry about if nobody's
being charged with it anyway it's just
going to stay there and it's going to be
left alone
representative Pru would you like to
speak to your second
no thank you it's open for discussion um
Representative Newell
thank you Mr chair uh I do have an
amendment uh for this bill i just handed
it out um I'm not sure exactly how that
works if I can introduce it um we we um
we're in discussion so we can you can
discuss the amendment um and sure tell
us why it would be a good idea to adopt
it okay so um the the bill itself uh I
think that's a pretty accurate
description of what the bill does um
although you know as as uh my colleague
said we we have heard that this has not
been an issue and uh that there is a
difference um that uh this is
unnecessary for the uh for the penalties
to be that high um what the amendment
does is it it actually just uh
accommodates the rest of the bill so if
this is going to be instituted there are
places in the statute where it needed to
be updated so really the amendment is
just kind of a a housekeeping saying if
if we were to change this if we were to
pass this bill we would need to update
other areas of the statute in order to
do that so the the amendment doesn't
necessarily doesn't well really doesn't
change anything about the initial uh
intent or what the bill does in the
first place it's just housekeeping so
the the amendment is if we're going
there anyway let's do this while we're
here type of thing okay so did you want
to tell us about why the bill is a good
idea then sure yeah i I think it only
makes sense uh and we have only heard
from folks who um we've only heard from
folks that this is not uh this has not
been an issue um I know last year or
maybe it was two years ago um we went
over uh very similar legislation and um
fundamentally the the idea was that
these um these consequences were or
penalties were set so high because there
was a fear um that that folks who uh
participated in the program uh might
engage in in um you know profit off of
that and and take advantage of that
situation we have not seen that happen
um and so really I think this is just
kind of meeting the moment um and the
fact that that we really don't need to
hold uh them to such a high standard it
it it has not proven to be the case and
you know many people even who were
supportive of this uh being structured
in this way in the first place you know
have looked back and said yeah we we
really haven't encountered any of these
issues and there's no need for us to set
the penalties that high
thank you further discussion represent
Muse and I don't have a question yeah a
person who actually does this is already
subject to the revocation of their
registry card and they're also subject
uh to a class fa class a felony for
violating the uh the control drug act so
to actually have a separate penalty on
top of that uh for something like this
seems excessive and as Representative
Newell said I I think back in the day
when we were you know first wondering
you know how people would behave uh when
uh when therapeutic cannabis became uh
legalized I think that there uh there it
was part of a compromise to actually
adopt that that that penalty uh but
because of the experience we've had over
the last few years it seems excessive
and even though there may not be a lot
of people who are actually charged with
it the idea of charging somebody with a
class A felony and another felony on top
of that um seems extremely excessive for
a drug that we've actually agreed to
legalize in this committee this year so
I I would urge we take a a second look
at this
represent Murray
thank you Mr chair um yeah I really want
to uplift what my um two colleagues have
said already but this isn't removing
penalties entirely it's just eliminating
duplicative penalties and um when
individuals were testifying basically
all the testimony we got on this bill
was in support including from DHS who
believes the current statutes are
outdated and not relevant anymore and um
one member who came to testify described
this basically as the exact definition
of discrimination because we are uh
penalizing people because of their
status doing an extra penalty because of
their status as a therapeutic cannabis
patient and not anything to do with the
actual you know quote unquote crime
itself because they're already getting
the same penalty as everyone else for
for selling if they did and then like
Representative Muse said they would also
be losing their medical card so this is
just giving another like felony just for
the sake of it um and that's why it's
duplicative and not necessary at this
point um and I really hope yeah that
everyone can um give this another
thought
thank you any further discussion
seeing none um I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role the motion on
floors ITL
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Pernell yes representative Pquette yes
representative Sabor Shaneer yes
representative Peoples
yes representative Linda Harriet
Gathight no representative Muse no
representative Newman no representative
Murphy no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no chairman Roy
chair votes yes 96 96 um motion
carries um minority reports let me see
what is today today's Friday um by
Monday morning please and I hereby close
the executive session i hereby open the
executive session of House Bill 387 and
I recognize Representative Lels for a
motion
yes Mr chairman thank you uh I move
ought to pass on H bill 387
second seconded by Representative Pru
would you like to speak to your motion
repres so
yes this is the uh famous balloon bill
which is
um it's meant
to send a signal for folks who are
um
well-meaningly celebrating some sort of
uh uh occasion and turning loose uh 20
or more helium filled
balloons to uh go up into the atmosphere
this this isn't meant
to totally throw somebody in jail
because of this because we understand it
has become kind of a cultural thing but
we know that these balloons when they
land they are they are particularly
uh bad for wildlife whether it be birds
or fish or whatever so I think this is a
good bill uh for uh sending a signal to
folks that it's not okay even though
it's pretty and it's fun and all that
sort of thing it's not okay to send all
these balloons up in the air because
they have to land somewhere
thank you representative Pru would you
like to speak to your second so I agree
wholeheartedly uh especially the effect
on the
wildlife in on the planet and I get it
it's a nice thing to do but we really
need to start changing that to take care
of our environment
um and our wildlife we owe them that
thank you um I would just reiterate that
this bill the penalty is a violation
level offense with a fine and you have
to um release more than 20 of these
balloons so um to Representative Lel's
point we're not you know trying to throw
the book at anyone but we do want to
raise awareness and see if we can't curb
these these things being released into
the into the wildlife further discussion
represent Muse yeah I'd just like to add
this is an important bill to those of us
who live in in coastal communities most
of the states who have enacted this bill
already are coastal states like New
Hampshire uh we have uh a huge uh
estruary system we've got Great Bay uh
we've got Segamore Creek um we don't
have much coastline but what we have uh
is is worth protecting and the wildlife
in it is worth protecting too so I'm
happy we're moving in this direction
thank you further discussion seeing none
I ask the clerk to call the role the
motion on the floor is ought to pass
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru yes representative Wels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Pernell
yes representative Pquette yes
representative Saborier
yes representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Greight yes
representative Muse
yes representative Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
chairman Roy chair votes yes 150 150 any
objection to consent seeing none it will
go on consent i hereby close the
executive
session with that I open the executive
session on House Bill 405 and I was
going to ask Representative uh Harry
Gather if someone
Oh excuse me i'm never mind 397 um and
ask if someone would like to make a
motion
oh I'm sorry yes um I make a motion that
we
um are to pass on HP 397
i'll second it would you like to speak
to your motion um no we had quite a bit
of testimony on it i think we're good
any any further discussion
seeing none I'd ask clerk what
very very quickly we we did hear a lot
of support uh from lake associations for
this bill and and I think it's important
for us to res to be responsive to that
kind of feedback these are the people
who are closest to the situation who are
the most affected uh so I'm glad we're
listening to them thank you um seeing no
further discussion the motion on the
floor is ought to pass i ask clerk to
call the role vice Chair Rhodess yes
representative Pru yes representative
Lels yes representative Devoid yes
representative Pernell yes
representative Pquette yes
representative Saborn Shaneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harriet Guthrighte yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes chairman Roy chair votes yes 150 any
objection to consent seeing none it will
go on consent i close the executive
session i open the executive session on
House Bill 405 and recognize
Representative Rhodess to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman um I move
amendment
0811H for House Bill 405
seconded by
Representative We
Yeah um we'll take five minutes for
everyone to go ahead and take a look at
that five minutes for everyone to take a
look at that amendment
that's not
I want to unplug this thing
19 balloons
well there's got to be a number
somewhere i mean five is just as
dangerous but
Okay we're back
thank you Mr chairman so the amendment
has uh two parts it's it's the the whole
amendment as you can see is is rather
long um so the original this is a
replace all by the way so the original
bill came to us and it was to be a a
study commission for human trafficking
sex trafficking so we've really come to
the conclusion that this particular
subject has been studied it has been
intensely looked at over the last couple
of years and what we found is we have
all these different task force that are
all working on this they're doing great
things but they're all doing it
individually so what we decided to do
was actually make a commission not a not
a study committee so now the commission
is going to bring all of those
stakeholders that have done all of this
intense work bring them to the same
table at the same time so that there can
be one or many written goals that
everybody agrees to and is working at
the at the same towards at the same time
towards that exact goal additionally we
asked for the interim study report so if
we do have to bring out future
legislation the hope would be that we
can bring it out whenever we all come
back at the beginning of next
year um the other piece is oh and if you
look we also made it say elicit massage
parlors we want to be very clear that we
are not saying that a person is running
a massage parlor is doing that illegally
that is why it specifically says elicit
massage businesses we do not want
anybody to think that we're confusing
therapeutic massage businesses with
elicit massage businesses um the other
piece is we have an increased penalty so
it is already it's a misdemeanor if you
are allowing a person to use say a a a
front to do these kind of horrific
crimes so we have made that be instead
of a misdemeanor it's going to be a
class B felony if the person that is
forced into this horrific life is a
minor it is going to be a class A
felony and that's a very short synopsis
of all of this thank you representative
U Murray did you second this i did would
you like to speak to that i think uh the
vice chair covered it very well thank
you further discussion
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to call
the role the motion is to adopt the
amendment vice Chair Rhodess yes
representative Pru yes representative
Lels yes representative Dvoid yes
representative Pernell yes
representative Pquette yes
representative Sabori Shaneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harriet Gath yes
representative Muse
yes representative Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
chairman Roy chair votes yes 150 the
amendment is adopted um Representative
Rhodess would you like to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman i move also pass
as amended for House Bill 405
seconded by Representative Murray would
you like to speak further to your motion
no thank you representative
Murray further discussion yes
representative Muse
i I wanted to say that one of the things
that we are uh typically reluctant to do
is to increase a penalty and and one of
the things that I wanted to do is to
point out that the penalties in this
bill are not enhanced penalties or
increased penalties uh for anybody what
we're doing is we're penalizing uh a
different group of actors so under our
current statute um uh trafficking uh in
minors or forcing other people into
trafficking is already a class A felony
uh what this particular uh penalty
clause would do is it would penalize the
operators of these illicit trafficking
facilities uh the people who secure the
leases the people who make it easy for
these folks to jump around from place to
place to place in our communities um my
understanding is we have six places like
this a half a dozen places like this
already on the sea coast um and we have
to do something about it i think the
fact that Massachusetts has changed
their law to something similar as New
Hampshire uh has really forced us to act
on this uh and I hope uh that this bill
will have the effect that we want it to
have thank you thank you um I I would
add to that as well i I agree the um
this problem right now is is
particularly disturbing because it's
it's not just one of um prostitution
it's one of forced um trafficking and
prostitution and it bothers me greatly
to know that you know every night when I
go to bed that there's women in the
state of New Hampshire who are being
held against their will and forced to do
this somewhere and I hope that this is a
first step towards eradicating this this
blight on our society and towards
freeing these women um with that I ask
the clerk to call the role the motion is
ought to pass with amendment vice Chair
Rhodess yes representative Pru yes
representative Lasels yes representative
Devoid yes representative Pernau yes
representative Pquette yes
representative Saborer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Gothright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes chairman Roy chairs yes 15-0 any
objection to consent seeing none it will
go on consent i close the executive
session i hereby open the executive
session on House Bill which I don't know
[Music]
416 and this is um I recognize myself to
make a motion i I'm going to move that
we reconsider um House Bill 416 we
actually took action on this already um
and we held on to it and I had made a
commitment to the sponsor to wait for an
amendment and it totally got away from
me um and that amendment has since been
brought and I I believe this is a good
bill that we should take a second look
at so um my motion is to reconsider need
a second seconded by Representative
Murphy um and I believe I just spoke to
it already so I would ask the clerk to
call the role the motion is to
reconsider House Bill 416
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru yes representative Lels
yes representative Devoid yes
representative Pernell yes
representative Pquette yes
representative Saborer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Gothreite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes chairman Roy chair votes yes 150 150
the motion to reconsider passes um at
this
point the motion retain
so the way this works now I believe is
we're going to um vote again the last
motion was to retain and we're going to
vote hopefully not to retain and then I
will make a new motion so um I'd ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is on
retaining House Bill 416
no vice Chair Rhodess
no
representative Pru no representative
Lels no representative Devoid no
representative Pernell no representative
Pquette no representative Saborer no
representative Peoples no representative
Harry Greight no representative Muse no
representative Newman no representative
Murphy no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no chairman Roy
Cher votes no 15 the motion for
retaining fails i recognize myself to
make a motion and I would
introduce amendment number
0191H um
second by representative PU sorry
um and this amendment was provided um to
me by the sponsor and it changes the um
the authority to enforce this is to all
officers in the state um we already
discussed what it does it um people
throwing yard waste into the lakes and
ponds um in the first offense any person
who purposely recklessly violates this
paragraph shall be guilty of a violation
it's just a violation it's um no one's
going to jail this is really again
almost like the balloons to raise public
awareness so that people understand hey
you can't be throwing the stuff from
your yard into the pond or into the lake
because it will cause these algae blooms
which are very expensive um for local
residents it's bad for the wildlife um
it's bad for tourism it's bad for a lot
of things so um further
discussion representative Murphy thank
you Mr chairman um I agree and fully
support this amendment i think this is a
step in one of the things that we're
trying to do as a state um in terms of
environmental and public health
protection and uh this just furthers it
i agree too about violation level um
status i you know education and
information provided to citizens is
important and I think that's a first
step and this is would serve as a
reminder but also address the problem
when people don't care or don't uh uh re
respond appropriately so I think it's a
great bill uh and I fully support the
amendment and um we'll support it when
we get a vote thank you Representative P
i think this is a good uh first step uh
and I would like to hope that if this
continues that we step up the penalties
to drive the PO point home because I
believe doing this is going to have a
large impact on our waterways if we
don't stop it thank you Representative
um Representative Lel
yes I would like to lend my support to
this also um I think it's a matter of
education and if if you can go to your
neighbor who has been thrown yard waste
in the lake forever and say "Hey have
you heard that this is no longer okay
it's against the law to do this." Most
good neighbors would then say "Oh I
didn't realize that and I'll stop that."
So I think there's an attitudinal change
a cultural change that has to take place
and uh like the balloon we're not going
to throw anybody in jail it's just a
matter of people understanding that it's
not okay to do this thank you
Representative um I I would also point
out that you know our immediately comes
to mind is you know your your neighbor
just doing but there's there's lawn care
people that come through and might do
you know nine or 10 houses are on a lake
and that's a lot of stuff if they decide
they're going to dump it in the in the
in the water um versus go to the
landfill maybe have to pay so it's
important to do this further discussion
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to call
the role the motion is to adopt the
amendment
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid
yes representative Pernell yes
representative Pquette yes
representative Saborn Shaneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Greight yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes chairman Roy gerald yes 150 150 so
the amendment is adopted i recognize
myself for a motion of ought to pass
with amendment second second by
representative uh Murphy any further
discussion seeing none I'd ask the clerk
to call the role ought to pass with
amendment
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru absolutely representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Patternau yes representative Pquette yes
representative Saborneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Gothright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes chairman Roy Gerald yes 150 150 any
objection to consent seeing none it goes
on consent i close the executive session
i open the executive session on House
Bill 445 recognize myself to make a
motion um and I move ought to pass
second seconded by Representative
Rhodess this bill um I brought this bill
because of a couple things i I've been
working with the um law enforcement now
for a while in New Hampshire um as in
part as my role as a member of the
accreditation commission and also as a
head of this committee and one thing
that I think we all have become aware of
is the
the unbelievable lack of um law
enforcement people willing to work in
the field um every department I know is
having a hard time recruiting
everybody's short and I think that we
need to come together um the various
agencies in the state and law
enforcement and put our heads together
and how we can address this and how we
can increase recruitment and entice
people um from the military from
universities from high schools to think
about law enforcement as a career and
look at what might be holding people
back from doing so um one of my ideas
that I had that I would like them to
look at is cooperating with a university
system to help possibly get some type of
tuition waiverss for people who have
agreed to serve for a certain amount of
time and things of that nature so I I
this is a a very serious problem for our
law enforcement in the state right now
and I would ask for everyone's support
would you like to speak to your second
and further
discussion than um muse
this is a time when it's increasingly
difficult uh to attract folks uh to
public service um and uh I think law
enforcement uh to a large extent is
bearing the brunt of this but we're also
seeing this uh increasingly in other
areas too so I think that sending the
message that public service has value uh
real value to our state uh and to our
country uh is a good thing so I'll be
supporting this bill thank you um
Representative Lel
yes I I also will be supporting this
bill and I think it's important that we
expand the horizons with respect to our
recruiting efforts and if we can entice
people
who don't necessarily have a tie to New
Hampshire but are from outside of the
region then we we increase the um the
ethnic the racial composite of the
people that are uh are applying for our
positions and I think that's a good
thing and if we are so parochial that we
restrict our our recruitment to just uh
you know our nephews or something that's
not good we have to expand our horizons
so I'm in whole wholehearted support to
this thank you representative any
further discussion seeing none the
motion of floor is ought to pass and I'd
ask the clerk to call the role vice
Chair RHS yes representative Pru yes
representative Lels yes representative
Pernau yes or sorry wait well sure
representative Devoid yes representative
Pquette yes representative Sabor Shaneer
yes representative Peoples yes
representative Harriet Guthright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes chairman Roy chair votes yes 150
any objection to consent seeing none it
goes on consent i close the executive
session i open the executive session of
House Bill 466 recognize myself to make
a motion i move ought to pass second
seconded by Representative Rhodess um
I'll speak to my motion hb 466 was
brought um at the request of the
Department of Safety uh Department of
Safety pointed out to us that we have
one of if not the lowest um rates of of
people consenting to take the
breathalyzer tests in the country um our
accidents and fatalities due to drunken
driving are are getting worse our roads
are getting more dangerous and we have
to do something our right now there's no
difference between refusing to take the
breath test or taking the breath test
the penalty is the same so why would
anyone take the breath test and give the
evidence of their of their uh in
insubriety to the police so what this
does is it breaks that so that it
is a more uh harsher penalty if you
refuse to take the test it also on the
other end does away with the minimum
mandatory sentence if you're convicted
on one part of it so it it's a good
balancing act and it just makes it just
a little bit stiffer so that people are
incentivized to cooperate and take the
test and it's important to remind people
that as part of accepting the driver's
license they agree in advance to do this
and we need to remind them that they're
violating that agreement by not taking
the test um further discussion
representative Muse
one of the one of the things about this
bill is that with the advent of body
cams um
uh the advantage of breathalyzer consent
I think uh is a little bit more
questionable than it's been in the past
um body cams have become much more
prevalent um uh I also think that this
is taking somebody's license away uh in
a state like New Hampshire when we
already have penalties that allow their
license to be taken away for for this
offense um it can be really be a
life-changing type of a type of an
impact uh for people i know that one of
the things we've discussed when this
bill has come up before us before um is
the need uh or the desiraability uh for
the state police and other agencies to
do more communication so people
understand the penalties for refusal um
I haven't seen that i've looked for it i
look for it online um um I don't think
anything like that has been done and I
think all that's happened is the same
bill uh that came before us last year
was resubmitted again this year uh with
really not anything having been done so
uh it's hard for me to support this one
thank you Representative Pru
so I get it having your license taken
away because you're out driving
drunk affects your life what really
affects somebody's life is when that
drunk driver hits an innocent family
because they got let off easy because
they refused to take the test so taking
the test should be the deal um if you
choose not to it should be at least the
same penalty if not worse than taking
the test you at least have a chance of
proving that you're innocent by taking
the test so I will be supporting this
110%
thank
you i will I'll close by saying that
this um as I said this was brought um
and the representatives correct it was
brought last year um the same people at
the department of safety um um Mr
edwards has asked me to file it again
and since last year there's been more
deaths and more accidents due to drunk
driving and that's why they they brought
it um and so really nothing's changed
the only thing that's changed from now
to then is that this year it's it's
going to pass so um I'd ask the clerk to
call the role the motion on the floor is
ought to pass
vice Chair Rot yes representative Pru
yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Pernell yes representative Pquette yes
representative Sabori Schwaneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Gthright no
representative Muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy yes
representative or the clerk votes no
representative Newell no uh Chairman Roy
chair yes 105 105 motion carries and I
hereby close the executive
session and we're going to take a
10-minute recess before we take up the
next one
i apologize for the delay um which one
are we on now
with that I open the executive session
on House Bill 473 and I
recognize Representative Rhodess to make
a motion thank you Mr chairman um I move
ought to pass um amendment 0430H
a second seconded by Representative
Murray would you like to speak to your
motion uh sure Mr chairman um so I have
the the original bill here in front of
me and I and I do have a lot of notes
but this specific amendment um we had a
gentleman
testify and he was talking about
whenever you have a minor that may have
therapeutic cannabis um most likely the
adult is the one that is retrieving that
and then giving it to the child um he
brought up actually a a very good reason
of why he thought that that exception um
needed to be made and it would be put in
it's uh on the page two of the original
bill it's line 26 that I have
highlighted in this amendment will
actually address that and uh I believe
the sponsor was here when that was being
said i advised them if they wanted to
make this happen and by God they did so
here we go
would you like to speak to your second
represent Murray
um I think the vice chair spoke to it
very well but I think um it's
appropriate when passing this
legislation to make sure that we're
treating um therapeutic cannabis the
same as we are treating other
prescriptions
except it's not a prescription yes
um okay further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role the motions to
adopt the amendment
vice Chair Rot yes representative Pru
yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Pednau yes representative Pquette yes
representative Sabori Schwaneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Greight yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Shear yes chairman Roy
she votes yes 16 the um amendment is
adopted i recognize Representative
Rhodess to make another motion
mr chairman I move uh to pass as amended
for House Bill 473
seconded by Representative Murray would
you like to speak further on your motion
um so the the bill in front of us um is
as all of us are aware in this committee
we're always hearing about more drugs
that are introduced that so they
continuously are adding to the
controlled drug substance list um so
basically what this bill does and you
look all through here is anywhere
methamphetamine related is written
they've they've edited that to say
control drugreated um they've also added
to a person's vehicle to also be
included with um uh property and I
believe that is it but I'm I'm sure that
I will be corrected if I'm wrong thank
you further discussion representative
New
um so I thank you Mr chair um I agree
with the the bill overall i do have some
concerns mostly around the language and
and how we've expressed this and so
essentially what what we've done on or
what the existing language is um
particularly as it was as it stood
around methamphetamine um it talked
about a variety of different situations
where this may make sense or where this
would apply um so page one line 24 no
person shall knowingly engage in any of
the following activities in the presence
of a child or vulnerable adult and then
it it gives this is one example right
and then the next example is in the
residence of a child or vulnerable adult
and then the ne next example is in a
building blah blah blah so it does it is
kind of separating it's not saying and
and it's not that like the in the
presence applies to everything and one
of the two of the um examples that it
gives is it says in a room being offered
to the public for overnight
accommodations or in any multiple unit
residential building and I I just have
deep concerns that um that this is vague
enough to allow for you know someone who
is staying in a hotel room who you know
for example did not know that there was
residue from someone doing this before
that this might be um something that was
left over it it leaves room in my
opinion um it leaves room for uh
misunderstandings of the law because of
just those those two particular things
and those those two particular things
being um examples where this would apply
um so those are my concerns i haven't
decided yet whether I'm going to how I'm
going to vote on um the overall bill and
I I honestly wish that um that that
could just be kind of sectioned out in a
way that that really provides for uh a
lack of misunderstanding in that
situation
okay that makes sense um I would say
this this is a first a first committee
it's going to a second committee is
going to finance if you feel like you
could support it with an amendment you
we just don't have time to do anything
further with it at this point um one
second Representative Rhodess thank you
Mr chairman ju just in in a response to
um Representative Null I think the
example that you gave I I think that's
valid but when I when I actually step
back for a second and imagine that
scenario I think if I were to go into a
hotel room with my child and I were to
notice something like that the first
thing I'm I'm going to do is obviously
go to somebody at the front desk and ask
for another room and then I would think
at that point the authorities are
probably going to be called so I I think
it obviously this is going after someone
that knows that they're doing that right
and so I I with respect I don't I don't
really see the example that you're
trying to give as even being something
that would be remotely confused with
that cuz you as the parent didn't do
that like you went into a room and that
was happening and obviously you're
removing your child and yourself as soon
as you see that as a situation so but I
I could be I misunderstand it doesn't
Doesn't it say knowingly yeah it does
okay so yeah you'd have to prove that
that Representative um Sher
um that was my point every all the
residences or types of rooms or
buildings referred to in that section
Roman numeral one it starts out saying
no person shall knowingly engage in any
of the following activities and then at
the end of that section has a through d
so somebody being knowingly present in a
place where there are drugs and there
are kids but is not manufacturing or
attempting to manufacture storing any
chemical substance etc as long as
they're not doing any of those A through
D they're not going to be in trouble so
if they come into a room that was rented
to somebody before and there is drug
residue there um they're not going to be
in trouble unless they start doing any
one of A through D thank you
um okay representative Newman
so I have I just have a question while
I'm thinking about this when this law
and it applies to the people and does
all the things that it says what is the
kind of things of circumstances where
they're going to find this how how how
will how will this come to the attention
of law
enforcement in any of the circumstances
i would suggest probably through an
investigation of um like DCYF or
somebody's there uh social workers there
and they see this and they report it to
law enforcement um something like that
um let me see what you say i said
schools yeah or schools could tell
parents all the time yeah representative
Murray or like what I've seen it come up
before is if a uh minor has taken to the
hospital because they've ingested
something and then it's usually oh it's
Yeah and then the healthcare workers I
assume I think are mandatory reporters
and there would then be investigation
based on like how did this child get you
know how were they able to ingest this
stuff and then they would be able to
prosecute the parents for exposing them
to that
can ask one question so in this it seems
to be the motel room situation so
somebody goes there they go with their
kid there's there's drugs left by
somebody in a drawer somewhere they
don't ever see it and they check out
they clean the room the next day and
then they find the drugs in the drawer
there and the pre the own the previous
person obviously spent the night in a
room that had drugs in it but had no
knowledge of it would would that happen
or would they have to go to court and
then defend themselves that goes back to
the knowingly and furthermore um the
police in any scenario like that would
have a really high bar to figure out to
tie that that in a common used area like
that just wanted to No no no
representative chair and also they're
not doing any of the A through D
that's important to note that
um it's no it's no secret that I believe
that this case is um this this is tied
to a specific case um the impetus for
this we um there was another suggested
amendment that I'm not going to take up
it's not from the committee but it it
would increase the statute of
limitations um to 10 years and I'm I'm
disincined to take that up because in my
mind that um it really borders on a bill
of attainer because that this is um
specific to a certain case and while it
may not technically be it certainly
violates the spirit of that
constitutional amendment where you put
something to get a certain person um and
if we want to charge a certain person if
we have to extend the statute of
limitations to do that in my mind that's
really walking the line of bill of
attainers um which would be
unconstitutional um I I know bill of
attainers where you actually charge
someone but um I just don't like the
idea of doing that to get one person
because you end up catching other people
in in your net that you've thrown and
whenever you extend statute limitations
it's not good um for either party you
end up with witnesses disappearing or
memories failing and testimony changing
the every year that goes by the case
gets worse um and 10 years is a long
time to have to keep be able to defend
yourself and remember where you were and
who was there and who you spoke to um I
can barely remember yesterday so that's
um why just for everyone's information
why I'm not taking that represent yep
is that the January
no it's one I got this morning someone
handed me it's not from this committee
it's
Oh maybe yeah I don't know it's
Yeah is anyone want to discuss that
further no okay seeing none the um
motion on the floor is ought to pass
with amendment correct we adopted the
amendment yes
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Pernau yes representative Pette yes
representative Saborer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harriet Guthrie yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes uh Representative Shear yes chairman
Roy Gerald's yes 16 any objection to
consent see a none will go on consent
and hereby close the executive session i
open the executive session on
[Music]
HP482 and this I recognize myself for a
motion i move ought to pass
second second by Representative Rhodess
this is another bill that was brought to
me by the Department of Safety this is a
very important bill for them um and for
all of us they
testified and told us how the accidents
severity of the accidents and the deaths
are are increasing on our highways for
people driving over 100 miles an hour um
you know I I like to go fast as much as
the next guy but when you're getting
over a 100 miles an hour the impact of a
vehicle collision against another
vehicle coming your way um is
astronomical and the chances of
surviving it are pretty close to zero um
a lot of these folks are from out of
state they're coming up on the fast
motorcycles and their their cars and and
especially during the summer and it's
causing people to die um so what that
they've asked is to stiffen the penalty
um so it's going to say "Now whoever
upon any way drives a vehicle at a speed
100 mph or greater and thereby violates
any of the provisions of this title or
any rule adopted by the director shall
be notwithstanding the provisions of
section Oh what is that lx11 come on."
Somebody who has their uh Roman numerals
down what is that 16 or 16
what's L lx is L LV
kids if you're following pay attention
in school um 62
guilty of a violation fine not less than
$750 plus a penalty assessment for the
first offense and $1,000 plus penalty
assessment for subsequent offenses and
his or her license or operating
privileges shall be revoked for a period
of 90 days for the first offense and
from 90 days to one year for a
subsequent offense so you get caught
going 100 you lose your license for 90
days and you get a $750 fine you do it
again you get a $1,000 fine and you can
lose it anywhere from 90 to a year
depending on the judge i think this is
uh sending a serious message that if you
want to drive on our ways keep it to 99
and under and further
discussion I don't know if the state
police endorsed my last comment no
yes represent Muse thank God for I just
want to say that um this is really
egregious behavior so um I'm going to
vote for it but one of the things that
um that I that I do question is you know
our continuing reliance on increasing uh
penalties some of these people who are
driving over a 100 miles an hour have
$100,000 cars the fines aren't going to
make a great deal of difference to
people like that
um people like that are going to find
other ways to get around while their
license is in suspension um so one of
the things that I would ask in the in
the future is that we think beyond
increasing penalties what are some of
the other things that we could
realistically do to to do something
about this problem uh because our our
solution always seems to be gee if we
increase the penalties it'll send a
message that we'll change
behavior but we'll we're still going to
have people who are going to drive over
100 miles an hour on our roads so you
know in a in a similar way to the way I
think we've responded to fentanyl with
kind of all of the above uh list of
solutions is I think we kind of need a
all of the above list of solutions to
problems like this and and so in in the
future it would be great to see more
things like that come in front of us
thank you any further discussion
representative Lels
I I would like to uh back up what uh
Representative Muse just said and in my
case I feel that we need increased
enforcement on uh some of these uh uh
situations and the way that I I feel it
would be good and I I know other people
do not agree but I noticed the other day
that you can now buy a car off the
dealer's
lot standard equipment more than 1,000
horsepower and I would submit to you
that no one needs a car with a,000
horsepower uh and what I would like to
see backing up what Representative Muse
said is that at the point of
registration that we
somehow put extra registration fees on
these high horsepower vehicles and then
give that to the to the public safety
department to increase enforcement
because I agree somebody that's that's
driving a Ferrari or something is not
going to be deterred by some
$200 fine for uh speeding so I would
like to see something uh uh tied to
horsepower at the point of registration
and then give it to the state please
thank you um I look forward to your bill
Representative Murphy
uh thank you Mr mr chairman um I am
certainly going to support this bill i
think any of us paying attention any
citizen paying attention only has to
listen to the news look at a newspaper
look online and daily we are seeing um
impaired drivers killing people killing
themselves causing accidents um we
certainly have a challenge with um
staffing law enforcement so the
enforcement is that much harder um
enforcing it is certainly um important
but having people do the right thing is
equally important um and I you know I'm
I understand um that you know we can't
find our way out of this or um there's
no one um solution but I think we have a
number of bills before us some that
we've already um heard and some that
that we've not yet exeact that will go
to addressing this because it's a huge
problem it's not going away nothing
we're doing right now is working so I
think it um this is it's a it's a step
that we need to take thank you i agree
um with everything that's been said
except for the part about not needing
the thousand horsepower so I I I totally
need a thousand horsepower um however
that being said I I agree we need to
look at um we need to look at everything
i I think that we should also look at
you know insurance um you know we get
penalized when we make a mistake but
there's not many benefits when you don't
i'd like to see the insurance companies
incentivize good driving more than they
do and bring some of our insurance rates
down um but that being said this is
about speeding and going over 100 miles
an hour and it seems like everyone's in
support so I'd ask the clerk to call the
role
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru yes representative Lelos yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Pernell
yes representative Pquette yes
representative Sabor Dishwiner yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harriet Gather yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman
yes representative Murphy yes
representative or the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Shear yes chairman Roy gerald yes 16 any
objection to consent seeing none of
consent i close the executive session
next i open the executive session on
House Bill
528 and I recognize Representative
Shabone oh no it is Representative Pette
sorry um I move to pass with amendment
uh 0488H
seconded by Representative Murray um so
this amendment changes the original bill
um the first one was a felony this
lessens the penalty to a uh violation
with a fine um it does not decriminalize
the use of psilocybin but it changes it
from a felony to a fine
thank you would you like to speak to
Okay would you like to speak to the
second represent Murray
sure thank you um I think it was clear
from testimony that um you know not only
is this not really um a dangerous drug
but it also has medicinal benefits that
people are unable to take advantage of
currently because of its classification
under the controlled drug act and while
um entirely removing it might be too
weak a step for this legislature to take
right now I think this is a good
compromise to start with and um
hopefully people will be able to
um treat you know their conditions if
they need to and not face um a felony um
for doing so thank you for the
discussion represent Muse
yeah I would like to say that um you
know during the public hearing we
actually heard some pretty compelling
testimony from one of our colleagues and
I think that really uh uh really helped
in in the past um we've heard that uh
psilocybin is uh extremely useful for
doing things like treating um uh PTSD uh
in in veterans um we've heard that it's
actually been a breakthrough uh
medication uh for folks who have dealt
with mental illness issues for many many
years um I I think where I'm at on this
is this particular uh this particular
change to the bill allows it to be
treated more like uh more like cannabis
uh from a penalty perspective and less
like fentanyl which I think is is a good
thing given the therapeutic benefits it
also gives us time to weigh and measure
what the potential therapeutic value of
this is to wait for studies to come out
um uh before we make any additional uh
decisions on what we're doing but at
this point uh it seems that if we
already have folks like state
representatives who are taking it to um
you know to to treat uh conditions that
they have and and we have constituents
who are also doing the same thing it
it's to me it's increasingly analogous
to uh to I think what we saw with
cannabis you know a decade ago so uh
it's time to to break the log jam and uh
and I hope we pass this
thank you um Representative Rhodess
thank you Mr chairman i I just want to
say
I I told the sponsor that I that I would
vote for his amendment he called he made
a a very compelling case um if if for
anything other than the fact that I have
tremendous respect for him and when he
testifies I he's the one person I ever
want to go up on the House floor against
um but I just have to say for the record
that all this conversation about this
being
medicine that's almost making me want to
say no i am not a doctor i don't know
that any of us in here are listen no
that's that's not right so if we're
doing this cuz we're taking away the
penalty that's one thing but doing it
cuz we're trying to say that we're
making it be medicine that's the part
that I'm not okay with i will vote for
it i'm saying that thank you further
discussion um I'm I'm torn on this i I
generally do not agree in full
legalization and as this does not do
that it reduces it from a felony which
is in line with the bill I passed or or
that I wrote that decriminalized or
defelonized first um first offense
possession um so I'm going to support
this i I do believe there is medicinal
value in this the the VA is looking into
it um but in order for us to to look at
it that way it's got to be done through
the proper processes which doesn't mean
um having our citizens at home
experimenting to see what makes them
feel better i'd like to see it done
through proper scientific channels
through university studies and the VA um
but having said that I support this bill
lowering it from a felony um we don't
need more intoxicated people but we also
don't need more felons so with that I'd
ask the clerk to call the role the
motions ought to pass with amendment or
did we adopt or no adoption of amendment
oh we got to adopt the amendment excuse
me vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru
yes on the amendment representative Lels
yes representative Devoid yes
representative Patternau yes
representative Pquette yes
representative Sabornne yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harriet Gather yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chair yes 16 any objection consent
no never mind it's still just the
amendment um further discussion seeing
none ask clerk what we have to make a
motion oh yeah i suppose you're right
motion OTP with amendment there you go
did you get both of those okay ask clerk
to call the role the motion is author to
pass with amendment
vice chair RHS yes representative Pru
reluctantly yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Pnau yes representative Pette yes
representative Sabor Daneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Gath yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy Cher yes 16
any objection to consent seeing none
it'll go on consent i hereby close the
executive session i open the executive
session on House Bill 551 and I I
recognize Representative Rhodess to make
a motion
representative
Pru representative Pru to make a motion
i make a motion to move
amendment 2025
05H I mean
058 3H
second second by Representative Rhodess
would you like to speak to your motion
well uh as I understand there used to be
a separate license before we had the uh
instant check system that if you were
selling to a person in the
state they had to reach back to the
local police department notify them that
they were selling this pistol the police
department would have to reach back and
say "Yes you can sell it to them or
not."
Uh so that has become
unnecessary there's still some
definitions about selling to an out
ofstate person that are left in here
uh again so I think it's just getting
rid of some an old law that is no longer
necessary or in use and uh removing that
separate license uh to sell a pistol
with all those things hanging over it
thank you representative Rose would you
like to speak to your second sure thank
you Mr chairman um so so the
amendment so the amendment is is
basically what Mr what Representative
Pru said um at the end of the day you
already have to have an FFL to sell a
firearm however you also still already
have to go to your town um either to
your planning board or your zoning board
to put in a business so the what the
amendment does is still leaves the other
part of the statute intact so you still
have to go through a license dealer if
you want to transfer a firearm from
someone out of state um there's always
question there's always this like this
this term this loophole but if I were to
go to say Pennsylvania and buy a firearm
I can't just bring that back to
Pennsylvania it has to be transferred to
an FFL here in New Hampshire i have to
go there to pick it up this keeps all
that still intact and it still keeps the
part about only being able to sell to
somebody you know personally um but the
the the separate license is no longer
needed because it being a federal
license
thank you um yeah
this in New Hampshire you have to have
two licenses if you want to sell guns
one of them from the feds and one from
local this just gets rid of the local
the local is a as was said an antique
left over from days before the the FFL
and the um instant background check
procedure so we're just doing away with
uh one and as Representative RH said the
the police department still kept in the
loop because you have to go to them
first to get your FFL because the the
the federal government calls them to
make sure they're aware that you're
getting an FFL um with that I'm going to
recess for 5 minutes so that um folks
can look at the amendment um just to
make sure they can read it so five
minutes if
you're making it okay because people
using it
All right I'm opening the executive
session on House Bill 218 FN um I
recognize Representative Rhodess making
a
Thank you Mr chairman i move ought to
pass for amendment 0765H
second make your amendment thank you so
we had a bill brought to us and um I
understand it was up in Wolfboro
somebody uh asked for an initial report
and for whatever reason was not given
that so since that original bill has
been filed that police department has
updated their policy so that they are
going to give somebody a copy of an
initial police report for a crime
however if you Google different police
departments in the state of New
Hampshire some police departments charge
$5 per page some charge if it's
electronic some don't charge anything at
all some charge of flat $20 the point is
that if you are the victim of a crime
you should not have to pay for the
police report that says you are the
victim of a crime when you receive that
you are able to start the process if you
need any kind of assistance um if you
need to hire an attorney some people
need to possibly get out of their lease
they have to move some people have to
miss work this report is going to make
it so that this amendment will make it
so that everybody is able to receive
something from the police department
that says that they have that they have
a police report that something happened
to them and be uniform across the state
it will all be free this is already in
the victim's bill of rights we added the
word initial report because we
understand that that there's generally
an investigation that follows after so
that is we we took the the victim's bill
of rights and we copied it into here and
we put the the time frames in there
because you know sometimes you have
holidays uh maybe the person that that
prints those things off is not there for
the day we just gave time frames so the
person knows that it will be coming the
max it's going to take is the 15 days or
the seven days
thank you further discussion
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman i agree with um
Representative Rhodess um I I think that
most of us are on the same page as to
recognizing that there's a need for
victims to be able to access something
in a very short time frame following a a
crime um for all the whether it's a
lease challenge or or for whatever
reason that they need time off from work
and they have to prove that there's a
reason why um the challenge is um and um
I have put out another amendment
um the challenge comes for me in that um
when I I asked for that first amendment
that we're talking about now um to be
written I didn't have some of the
information that I have now And I've
been told by as our my own chief of
police that that passing the amendment
as written would violate 91A it would
remove the ability of law enforcement
officers to withhold a that initial um
report uh it would be in conflict um and
his concern about that was that
sometimes there are uh there's
information in that report that if a
crime victim was still living with the
perpetrator the crime the perpetrator
would have information that they might
not the the um uh prosecuting uh agency
may not want them to have because it it
could mess up a case and the last thing
I want to do is make it harder for law
enforcement to prosecute cases and pro
protect victims um
so it it comes down
to the we're on the same page I think so
in in most of this and I think we're all
trying to do the right thing and the
same thing but I just can't support
um my own amendment uh um if it if I'm
being asked to to pass it knowing that
it will complicate the ability of law
enforcement and it will direct law
enforcement um agencies to do something
that 91A tells them that they have the
right to withhold so I just I don't know
how to without a different amendment I
don't know how to to make that happen
thank you um Representative Sher
uh thank you again i'm in support of the
idea here the concept here i just want
to make it as clear as possible
certainly um my role as a police
commissioner in Portsouth uh the police
hate
ambiguity and I think um the ambiguity
here is the word report
some people read the word report to mean
the report that the victim made to the
police other people read the word report
to mean a police report of what the
victim said many many times in police um
matters there is no written report
authored by the victim about what
happened the huge majority of reports
are oral reports to a police officer who
then writes a police report i go through
this lengthy and boring distinction
because there are police departments I
also know there are police departments
who view the word report in as it's
written as meaning a police report and
they see that covered by 91A
if there were
a Well I'll That's my problem here the
The Second Amendment that uh
Representative Mercy Murphy filed uh
required simply a a right to get a
confirmation that a crime was reported i
know there's difficulty about the word
alleged but you know I think that we can
get rid of that if need be but if if if
the if the victim is just asking for
confirmation that they reported a crime
on a particular date that occurred at a
particular location then we don't have
any problems but this word report just
mucks things up for police departments
thank you um I'm going to say this the
the victim's bill of rights is existing
law in that it says they have a right to
the police report
this says they have a replace to police
report merely that it's free and they
have so many days to give it the police
under 91A have the ability and the
authority to redact anything that they
feel um is covered under 91A under the
investigation exemption but they do not
have the right to withhold the entire
police report so I don't care if it's
the officer's written report or the
victim came in and gave them a written
report it it the clearly the victim's
right means the police report so this
means the police report and if they need
to redact it they can redact it and
still turn over the report and then the
victim is free to to pursue that further
if they saying they're redacted too much
we're just saying it's free and and I
think that's the point is at the end of
the day we copied the language of
existing law now you got to give it free
if the police say "Well that's a
violation of 91A," they can redact what
they feel is a violation that they don't
have to turn over um further
discussion seeing none what
representative um Newman I I just have a
question about the victim's bill of
rights that uses the word in the law of
police report does it have any
definition of that
and my followup would be is is there not
some way we can describe a short report
that report that they that a victim has
reported a crime and would that be
sufficient that's almost getting into a
um an unfunded mandate because they
don't do that you're we're asking them
in the amendment is asking them to
create a report they don't already do so
if a if a victim comes in and says "I
need this." The police would at that
point have to create a special report
just for that victim to say "You came in
on this date and and reported a crime."
And that's not something they're already
doing we'd asking them to create an
extra report um and I don't I don't
think that's what we're intending to do
here we're just talking about the
regular police report that goes to the
prosecutor um and if they need to redact
it they'll have to tell the victim
here's a redacted report because we're
it's still an open investigation um it's
in the representative Pette as someone
who's been a victim of crime and had to
get documentation to prove so um if I
asked for the police report I needed the
police report and I needed specific
information that was in the police
report um having a paper that says that
I was the victim of a
crime allegedly wouldn't be of any help
at all
thank you all right i'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is um
to adopt the amendment
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru
confused but yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Patternau yes representative Pquette yes
representative Saborn Disher yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Greight no
representative Muse yes representative
Newman
yes representative Murphy
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Shear no
chairman Roy cher yes 142 142 the
amendment is adopted representative RHS
would like to make a motion thank you Mr
chairman i move ought to pass as amended
for House Bill 218
seconded would you like to speak to the
motion um just just one sentence um the
word report has been in the domestic in
the uh domestic violence victims bill of
rights for 25 years and has always been
interpreted to mean initial thank you Mr
chairman thank
you um with that I'll ask the court to
call the role motion is ought to pass
with amendment
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Puit still confused but yes
representative Lels yes representative
Devoid yes representative Penernau yes
representative Pquette yes
representative Sabor Shaneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harriet Gathight no
representative Muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes
representative Shear no chairman Roy
chair votes yes 124 124 just enough to
make sure it cannot go in consent with
that the motion carries um again um
opposition reports are um it's not
opposition is not the word um minority
report uh are due by Monday please thank
you with that I close that executive
session
we have let me see 551 we're waiting on
a um on an
amendment
and 146 we're meeting on an amendment so
we'll be in recess check back again at I
guess 1 until we get those amendments
reopening executive session on House
Bill 146 um if you recall we
had an amendment and there was a
question as to whether or not the
amendment needed to be changed because
of the ABC and the amendment said it
replace section one with and it had a we
checked with OS and they said the
amendment is fine as it is it does not
affect the existing law it will
only replace the rest of the new bill
with just that so the the amendment is
fine as it is um according to all us if
I can actually find it
which bill are we talking about now and
they said no problem
okay if greater minds than mine
[Music]
you were talking about removing section
C it was ABC so they're saying that
because it says replace all of section
one with just A it remove C so
okay and this is the body one camera
bill um so I'm going to I don't We
didn't Didn't we didn't move this yet
already right this amendment
we did so then I'm going to leave it as
is
yeah myself and Representative Rhodess
already moved this amendment um last
week or earlier this week and did it
pass it's all good we did we vote moved
it but we didn't vote on We didn't vote
on it we stopped okay so what we're
going to do now is we're going to vote
on the amendment um that we already
moved when I recessed um earlier in the
week this amendment is good as is 0591h
yeah
0591h
um and for those who are here probably
wondering what are they talking about
like our our replacements um we had a
bill on body cameras
because body camera footage is only kept
for a certain amount of time and a
constituent of someone appealed a
traffic citation and by the time it got
to appeal they'd already destroyed the
evidence and he wanted to use it in his
defense so what this bill is doing is
saying if there is a violation level
offense you have to hold on to that
until it's resolved because prior to
that they didn't
okay all right with that I'll ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is um
adopt the amendment vice Chair Rhodess
yes representative Pru yes
representative Lels yes representative
Devoid yes representative Pernau yes
representative Pquette yes
representative Sabori yes representative
Peoples yes representative Harriet Gath
no representative Muse no representative
Newman
no
representative Murphy no the clerk votes
yes representative Newell yes
representative Shear yes chairman Roys
yes 124 124 motion carries would you
like to make another motion
Representative Rose move off to pass as
amended oh I'm Yes ot to pass as amended
i second that and with that I ask the
clerk to call the role wait a minute
does anyone want to talk about it
this is the bill itself and the last
turn on
sorry when we talked about it earlier my
understanding was that it was going to
be section C was going to be removed
where in the amendment the amendment
says the amendment says amend the bill
by replacing section one section one
contains A B and C okay now it's only
got A okay all right i guess but it says
because there's a B there's a there's a
B in statute
no C was going to be part of this new
bill but it's not anymore so now the and
refers just to the B that's already in
statute
okay
i know got it
it's a little confusing but it's what
happens when you have to pull parts of
statutes and replace them all right um
Okay with that I'll ask the clerk to
call the role motion is ought to pass as
amended
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pro yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Padenrell
yes representative Pquette yes
representative Sabor Dwaneer yes
representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Gather
i'm going to say no representative Muse
yes representative Newman
yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Shear yes chairman Roy
votes yes 151 151 will there be a Is
there an objection to consent
you do okay then I'll need a minority
report um with that the I close the
executive session
representative Murray what was it for
for the amendment please said 124 thank
you
she is oh I am oh yeah this was your
Yeah i hereby open executive session on
House Bill 551 and recognize
Representative um Roads
uh thank you Mr chairman um so we had
had a motion to to pass amendment
0583H um but I would like to withdraw
that motion and make a motion to pass 01
I'm sorry
0818 H i second that and would you like
to speak to the motion yes thank you Mr
chairman so the amendment is the exact
same amendment that I already handed you
um but Representative Shear noticed that
on line 28 the word l eee um needed to
be changed to the word person um to
match the rest of the amendment where
the word lency was taken out i thank him
for finding that and that's what it does
so if you already have the other
amendment it's it's the only thing
that's changed is one word on line 28
thank you further
discussion representative Sher um and uh
in all transparency it was
Representative uh Newman who first
picked this up thank you thanks
Representative
um any further discussion i think we
already talked about this this takes
I'll just recap it again for our um our
placement folks in New Hampshire statute
there's a law requiring someone who's
going to sell guns to get a New
Hampshire license and there's also the
federal license that you have to have um
this does away with the New Hampshire
license because why should we charge our
citizens for something they already have
to pay the federal government to get um
and that's basically
it um with that I'll ask the clerk to
call the role the motion is ought to
pass with amendment
or adoption of amendment oh yeah i'm
sorry we're a little premature or this
is to adopt the new amendment
vice Chair Rhodess yes representative
Pru yes representative Lels yes
representative Devoid yes representative
Pernell yes representative Pquette yes
representative Sabori Schwiner yes
representative uh Peoples yes
representative Harry Greight yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chair votes yes 160 the amendment is
adopted um I recognize Representative
Rhodess to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman i move
um ought to pass as amended for House
Bill 551
second any further discussion seeing
none I'll ask clerk to call the role the
motion on the floor is ought to pass
with amendment vice Chair Rhodess yes
representative Pru yep representative
Lels yes representative Devoid yes
representative Pernell yes
representative Pette yes representative
Saborer yes representative Peoples yes
representative Harry Gathright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Sheer yes chairman
Roy she votes yes 160 16-0 any objection
to consent seeing none go on consent
with that I close the executive session
um just for everyone's edification we
have we were scheduled next Friday to do
further executive sessions those have
been cancelled they're going to be moved
to the next week so next week the only
thing you have is house session um I do
need all the reports though from what
we've done this week no later than uh
Monday so I can get them over and
they'll be in the calendar for the
following week
just for the record um Representative
Harriet Gathroy has withdrawn her
objection to consent therefore that bill
will be going on the consent calendar
which number was that
146 will be on consent before we go i
mean
well that turned out better than I
thought and I don't know who's